MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20 Special Relativity.
In our quest to understand how
we get to general relativity,
there is two things to consider.
The first one,
this lecture is not
meant to give you
a full description
of general relativity,
but just a view into where
this might lead, where
this discussion might lead.
So in this quest,
we can understand
the theory of general
relativity as a theory on how
to patch together the different
reference frames which each can
be described in special
relativity, in the framework
we discussed up to now, and
it's valid in short intervals
in spacetime.
Consequences of
general relativity
are that spacetime is curved.
So we have modified geometries.
We learned that, because
of gravitational effects,
matter curves spacetime.
As a consequence
of that, there must
be modification of gravity
based on matter distributions,
and so there must also
be gravitational waves,
gravitational lenses which
bend light, black holes,
and there's cosmological
predictions coming out
of general relativity.
So let's have a
discussion first.
What does it mean to have a
changed or modified geometry?
What could that mean?
So you are all used to
Euclidean geometry, where,
when you draw a
triangle, you add up
all the angles to 180 degrees.
If you try to parallel
lines that never cross,
they also don't diverge.
But if you have a
modified geometry--
for example, the geometry on
a sphere, like on our globe--
the angles do not add
up to 180 degrees.
Actually, the sum is
larger than 180 degrees,
and parallel lines will cross.
We will call this kind of
space positively curved,
but you can have the opposite
example, like on a saddle.
So you can have other spaces
and other curved spaces,
and they can be
negatively curved.
In this example, if
you add up all angles,
you find they add up to
less than 180 degrees.
Parallel lines do not cross,
but they will diverge.
Mass changes the
geometry of spacetime.
We just talked
about light bending,
and because of the
change in geometry,
light will not go on a
straight line anymore,
but will bend around
massive objects.
Spacetime is curved.
Geometry of spacetime tells
us how the mass is moved.
You can think
about a trampoline.
When you put a heavy
object on a trampoline,
all the other objects
on the trampoline
will gravitate towards
the heavier object,
and that's kind of a picture
on how spacetime actually
looks like.
Einstein used those
findings in order
to redefine Newton's
first law and found
the so-called Einstein
field equation.
So on one side of
the equation, there's
a description of spacetime
and its curvature,
and on the other
side of the equation
is the energy momentum
tensor, the description
of how energy and momentum
of object is distributed.
And those two things, spacetime
and energy and momentum,
they're kind of interlinked
in this equation.
So if you read this
description, you
can read it from one
side to the next.
Spacetime tells
matter how to move.
Or you read from
the other direction,
say matter tells
spacetime how to curve.
That is an equation,
and you can just
read it from the
left to the right
or from the right to the left.
Our understanding here.
It says space and time
are not fixed things
through which matter and
energy moves through.
The matter and energy
themselves define spacetime.
And matter, because of
spacetime, is dynamical.
It's changing.
It's interacting with the
matter and with the energy.
This is a super exciting picture
from Hubble, the Hubble Space
Telescope.
And you see galaxies,
but what you also see
is those structures which
looks like the light has
come through lenses.
Those lenses are actually
matter distributions, galaxies,
which actually lead to
the bending of the light
and those lensing effects.
OK.
If you want to summarize
general relativity,
you can first say that
spacetime is curved
and it follows the
pseudo-Riemannian manifold
with a specific metric.
We have seen the metric before.
It's minus, plus, plus, plus.
And the relationship
between matter and curvature
is given by the
Einstein equation,
and here I give you a
slightly different form
where there is the
dynamics, again, on one side
and the energy momentum
on the other side.
Let's just look at
one example here.
So we discussed, in
special relativity,
invariant intervals, and
we have this delta squared,
or we have a
different name for it.
I given by minus dt squared
plus dx squared plus dy
squared plus dz squared, and
we could have just written
this in polar
coordinates as well,
where you find that dr
squared and r squared
d theta squared, and
then r squared sine
squared theta d phi squared.
OK.
Same thing.
It's just a different
coordinate system.
So as a solution to
Einstein equation,
we find something which
looks very, very similar.
That's not a surprise, as
we find general relativity
as a patchwork of small
spaces of special relativity.
So the solutions
might be very similar.
And the solution found here,
the so-called Schwarzschild
solution, which is a
unique solution in vacuum
with spherical symmetry
of a matter distribution.
So you have a spherical matter
distribution like our sun,
and this is a solution
which describes
spacetime around this.
You find this
invariant interval here
has two interesting features.
There's two
singularities in here.
This should be a minus 1.
You find those
two singularities.
One is at r equals 0.
That's kind of expected.
In the middle of the
mass distribution,
this thing is not
defined anymore.
There's no mass left.
But there's also a second
singularity at 2GM.
This is called the so-called
Schwarzschild radius,
and if you get to
the singularity,
you basically don't
define anymore
this invariant interval.
You can think about the
surface of a black hole
as this singularity.
At this r value, at
the singularities,
everything becomes timelike,
or everything within the radius
becomes timelike.